Die jüngste entdeckung macht hoffnung auf die besiedlung des mondes
das bisher nicht gelöste problem wasser jetzt wurden lover
Höhlen entdeckt die zum einen für eine mondstation perfekt liegen und zur anderen wassereis enthalten könnten wie ist die lage
auf dem mond jetzt bei klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Es ist eine der größten herausforderungen für eine mondstation wie kommen die bewohner innen an wasser von der erde zum mond
Transportieren würde unsummen kosten es muss in jedem fall dort gewonnen werden und wasser wurde ja schon auf dem mond gefunden allerdings
Ist es in reguliert gebunden in diesem gestein reagieren die protonen des sonnenwindes mit dem enthaltenen sauerstoff?
Und es entsteht wasser das allerdings nur in kleinen mengen existiert und schwer abzubauen ist und auch das mondgestein
enthält wasser in
homöopathischen dosen also minimal in schmelz einschlüssen aus der zeit als der mond noch vulkanisch aktiv war ist neben anderen
mineralien auch wasser eingeschlossen auch nur sehr schwer zu gewinnen mit
Den jetzt entdeckten höhen könnte dieses problem gelöst seien bei der auswertung von aufnahmen
Der nasa raumsonde luna rekord von peter lro hat ein forschungsteam jetzt lover höhlen entdeckt die möglicherweise
Wassereis enthalten die höhen liegen, im viel öl austrat er erst rund 70 kilometer groß und liegt auf
72 grad nördlicher breite des mondes rillen in der dicken laubschicht des kraters deuten auf lover hüllen hin
Würden diese höhlen jetzt eis enthalten wären sie perfekt für eine mondstation
Geeignet sie böten schutz und wasser zitat ich denke
ich könnte einen wirklich spannenden ort für die erkundung und möglicherweise sogar eine menschliche
Kolonie gefunden haben das sagt pascal I vom ames research center der nasa und vom
Seti institute in katar hat sein team jetzt öffnungen entdeckt die zwischen zehn und
30 metern groß sind und auch etwas macht die lage erhöhen zum einen extrem interessant und zum anderen die
Wahrscheinlichkeit für eis sehr hoch sie sind 550 kilometer vom nordpol des mondes entfernt und liegen auf der der erde
zugewandten seite mit ausreichend sonnenlicht zitat damit ist der krater außerhalb der dauerhaft beschatteten gebiete der lunaren
polargebieten das erklärt die damit kann dort einfach strom aus sonnenlicht hergestellt werden die höhlen werden wahrscheinlich aber auch kalt genug um 1
Zu enthalten wie eisel hier auf der erde und im gegensatz zu dem im mondgestein
alles viel leichter abzubauen die lage ermöglicht zudem die einfache kommunikation
Mit der erde weil die höhe neben der erde zugewandt sind zitat diese entdeckung ist aufregend und kommt gerade zur rechten zeit
Gerade wenn wir uns auf eine rückkehr des menschen zum mond vorbereiten so der präsident des goethe-instituts
Bild diamond jetzt müssen diese höhlen zunächst unbekannt erforscht werden um zu klären wie groß
Sie sind und ob sie wasser enthalten sobald es neues dazu gibt erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier
Wenn er kein video dazu und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann tut mir ein abo aufsaugen vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann
manipulierte algorithmus von youtube nicht die
benachrichtigung über neue videos und erfahrt auch wirklich dass ein neues video online gegangen ist hier also hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
Wasser auf den montag geht es um die funde von wasser. Im mondgestein ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran